what's up t-fat kz listeners
and viewers on youtube holler at your
boy uh
san marcos texas with the squad january
29th through the 30th
limited tickets available uh two shows
on friday two shows on saturday that is
this month
texas san marcos get tickets right now
some are sold out
tickets going fast tfatk.com for tickets
all thick boy gear thick boy hoodies
thick smiley face thick girl thick uh
boy
bike club trucker hats thick boy tie-dye
they got it all
at sickboy.com
this episode of fighter and the kids is
brought to you by on it supplements
listen it's 20 21 you're trying to get
your mind right try and get your body
right
let on it help you out put in your body
the best supplements on the planet we
talk in total gut health earth grown
nutrients
we got vitamin d3 spray all right uh
we got shroom tech glutamine creatine
protein
powder keto stuff we got everything you
need we got
uh fitness gear we got kettlebells steel
club maces
sandbags battle ropes on at six
streaming fitness so you can keep your
ass at home
you don't have to get worried about
getting sick stay at home get your
workout out and get your workouts
uh on lose weight get to shred city or
just stay thick like me and take these
supplements so your uh insides are
healthy
on it.com fighter tim shut off
yo that song's hard huh the baby never
like he really never misses
he really don't make a song he's missing
it's very rare it's very rare
especially on a feature oh no oh in the
future nothing better than the baby did
you
hear that song with him and j cole oh
yeah oh my god i have not oh
might kill more than anyone yeah yeah
because he came in i got the worst on
there i think with two chances
he goes y'all because baby get you hyped
what goes yeah the baby yeah
kanye and the two chains yeah and i was
nervous for two chains
what no two chains only killed it yeah i
know i know but you still get a little
nervous bro but especially on like a
kanye song
he comes on at the end remember like
that's that i don't like and then kanye
came in
i mean oh don't they don't like remix
yeah they don't like women
came in at the end come on man kanye's
in wyoming
oh yeah building he cooking right now uh
you're cooking a divorce
we yeah we they're separated i mean
she's she's in wyoming
i'm sorry he's in wyoming she's in l.a
jay told me about that what's what's
going on
i mean we have it as a current event if
you guys are just sick of this [ __ ]
but like but he's on medication though
yeah i know but he can only put up with
so much
you know what i'm saying
i think he was what manic depressive
bipolar yeah and then it
he was like when to rehab but they were
having issues before that
so i think she just from the optics
standpoint she's like well i don't want
divorce and while he's saying that he's
in rehab and like trying to get help
yeah so she waited for him to come out
she's all peace well i think they're
[ __ ] up because they haven't used dr
love
oh yeah you're right or dr dre oh okay i
love what you want with that shout out
that's current event we won't get into
it yeah i know but uh
i mean that's tough though because yeah
how would you help that situation
dr love uh family i don't know i think
we're talking about mental
illness that's yeah yeah tough i don't
deal with that situation but at the same
time
well there's so many kids involved she
knew he was crazy oh what i want to say
great he and she knew i think he got
worse
over corona you think corona buyers and
quarantine kind of like your hands
i just say as he gets older it's getting
worse and then
you know he's gotten super religious
like he's always been religious but now
it's like
i know he he holds i mean can you
imagine if like oh jesus walks was on
his first album
that's a little different though he's
still cussed and like talked about
arches and chains now he does like
sunday certainly now it's like
like and she's probably like damn every
sunday i believe in the
on the lord but [ __ ] dude like this is
what we're doing i want to ask you a
question
like religion is very important in the
relationship but like what
let's say someone's hands on a
relationship it depends on relation
let's say you started off and y'all just
cool and
you got married then some like some
tragic happened you found god
now you you know your significant other
is like she's balls
balls and you're like oh [ __ ] okay i'm
trying to support you but god damn
like what do you do it depends if she
was always pushing on me and the kids
like my girl got super religious she's
like we need to go to sunday service
whatever i'll go to church
we need bible study on wednesday when
you think the like i'm like you you need
to chill man
you know just from my experience the
most you know my grandma's super
religious i've had friends that are
super religious
they're the most judgmental people on
the planet oh religion
dude my religion's good for a lot of
reasons but man it can be bad for like
my grandfather used to invite like
uh jehovah witnesses in and he'll just
like to argue with him yeah
but i'm like yo are we all on the same
side i know like nah
it get heated it's like like a first
take debate is your is your mom
religious
no yeah no my dad and my mom both
muslims so they like
they're on the same page yeah but they
were born muslim though or they
converted it so
they converted my dad was like uh muslim
uh he converted like he's been
for years yeah yeah and then why did he
come did he
not he was on the street and then uh i
think like some gang stuff and then he
like you know everyone converts to islam
yeah
right same way so she had a pr player
so he met my mom my mom grew up in like
the catholic church she grew up
like very like religious so the fact
that he like had her
how are you going to let him convince
you to join that cult i was like hold on
granny oh
yeah oh you're so your grandparents
aren't nah they are catholic they ca
exactly so i grew up in both
so they this is so dope about my parents
because they didn't force it on us
thank you you know yeah so i'm saying
like yo they'll show you and then
i go to church so i grew up in a muslim
church and muslim churches they kind of
deep
like they'll call them they call it
temple right so
let's say like i go to a pastor right
and he's like super
god and like i'm that's and it's so long
on sunday
and then i go to a muslim temple uh
temple and it's like uh
very straightforward and they just like
use like analogies
you gotta pray like 70 times five times
five times a day yeah but i think that's
like uh ortho
uh unorthodox muslim oh really i think
he was more of like uh
uh the foi kind of likes i think that's
like different i didn't know it was just
like
foi is fruit of islam of islam yeah
yeah and then of islam correct yeah
that's what my dad is
that's what he did
[Laughter]
i
i didn't know your mama was a nurse yeah
at uh the
same hospital as caesar uh sinai yeah
and that's where dr dre went
yes did your mom get in that see what's
happening well she took she
know dr dre had an aneurysm she told me
not to say i don't want to get her oh
really yeah she said they they can lose
her pull her uh
car i do my uh my uh youngest son boston
was born at cedar you told me that maybe
your mama was uh
yeah that was the one i was the one i
know my mom probably yeah your mom could
have been the one congratulations your
mom could have been one
they say how about how about dr dre uh
how [ __ ] up are human beings
because they found out he had an
aneurysm and then these [ __ ] idiots
uh tried robbing his house because they
knew he wasn't there yep people were
trapped they disappoint you man people
disappoint you
right every time you caught them though
yeah they're cool yeah [ __ ] but
that's kind of like a boat that's
you can't ride yeah you can't rob the
guy well
his uh acts they're going through a
divorce which i'm sure helped with that
aneurysm i know
he uh she said she said he has a 175
million in cash
well so certainly you just put a bounty
on your boy's head why would she say
that i don't know
that's crazy and she wants two million a
month
in alimony and then five million for her
lawyer fees
[ __ ] you've had a lawyer for two weeks
and that's the thing about divorce is
it's so messy but at the end of the day
i think chris rock had a big
bit that like when i looked around this
table everybody's at this table
trying to take my money right they're
all like the guy pays more
you do not want to get lawyers involved
in anything because they're in cahoots
with each other
so they're they're it's not like they're
for their they're for their client and
then he's for me
no they're together because they're
they're gonna get the most money out of
me most money out of her
they're trying and then they both get
paid so that's why it drags on drags on
yeah
where's a [ __ ] man you do not
want to get them involved with
anything especially out here right la uh
california divorces drama straight
divorce
oh yeah at least worse right by far the
worse
you want to get married in florida or
texas i think why arizona
i don't know about i'm sure arizona is
cool too yeah there's something
yeah la's the worst even with if you do
have a prenuptial agreement
do you think that like l.a just like
bypassed that like uh
they don't bypass it but they definitely
favor the the women the women
yeah especially on that child support
all my friends
paying for that like out of how does the
way to go
is it just because is it just because uh
no health insurance
in a lot of these cases is it just
because the male makes more
not even my man work at costco and
literally they take
child support take out his check he get
he i'm talking about like in
in the relationship like okay so say
well they're saying you so let's say
let's say let's say you and your girl
get married this year yeah and then
let's say in five years you're kevin
hart you blow up
they're gonna say your success wouldn't
have happened without the help of that
of
that girl home [ __ ] down at the house
and she'll be through
kevin hart would be in kevin hart
whether that girl is there or not hate
to tell you yeah
tory hart damn yeah they know but they
give
they give those women the credit yeah of
like you like
success like you gave up your dreams so
he could so
you supported him so you gotta maintain
their lifestyle it's like really
is there some tests they can take to see
how skilled they are to see if they
would have made it without me yeah you
know
there's some sort of wonderlic test for
these [ __ ] damn that is stressful
like it's not cool man it's like bit
there the difference is so let's say
let's say you and your girl get married
this year and then you have kids and
there's two kids
and uh you and your girl both want to be
comics right
yeah and then you blow up in six years
and you're kevin hart
and your girl was like all right i'll
give up my dreams and i'm gonna be a mom
i'm a stay-at-home mom
that's different that's different that's
different because then yeah
yeah like she held down the fort she
raised the kids while you're out
even if kevin her and kevin hart didn't
have kids
she's she could still be like yeah oh
they could depend on how long
depends how long yeah yeah yeah and if
they have a prenup it gets dicey
oh kids kids make it really tough kids
make it tough
well listen it's a double standard
because like let's say
you women are always going to praise the
woman
get that bag sis but mary j blige is
going through the same situation her
husband is
killing her bank account and it was like
oh that's messed up all
now if you want to have it both ways
this guy said he put all he invested all
the mary j blodge
he wants his money is he hurt
no he got he got he's getting that money
what does he know what does he do
what do you mean oh he's not an
entertainment or anything i think he was
her manager early or something
similar things are happening with it
happened with britney spears and
with kevin fetterline because he was a
backup dancer and then i think
wendy williams and her husband too oh
one of them williams makes so much money
yep but her husband i think
owned part of her show the wendy
williams show and she
kicked him out uh while he was doing all
the like his cheating stuff because
there was a huge scandal about that
that's right but now he's trying to take
her for a lot of money
and yeah she has he's the one that
cheated yeah yeah
and she has a whole lifetime uh movie
coming out about it yeah this is uh
i can't wait so this is oh okay this is
mary j blige's uh ex-husband so he was
just a regular dude no but he was a
manager
he looks tired of [ __ ] right
not tired of getting that money he looks
exhausted but i'm saying it's a double
standard so now they're trying to like
really i mean there's a petition with
women trying to get her her money
back but the fact that like women praise
women the other but to defend mary j
blige with him it's like all right what
skill set did you have
yeah it's like what was our manager okay
okay okay so you could have any manager
making that money that's true
like he didn't make the moves and give
her the talent she did it on her own
of course yeah but you don't have any
management what the manager
that you have that deserves that sort of
money the damage
that much money so it's different well
yeah but he also the manager
you like navigate your career so he
probably could have told like no don't
do this do this deal and stuff like that
you gotta give him some kind oh do the
grammys thank you for that
here's 10 thank you for your words of
wisdom
but here's the thing it wasn't it was
like a you it was
killing bro he's togethernbc more than
that yes
[ __ ] and i feel bad i do feel bad that
does suck
i don't i don't understand the kevin
featherline situation with britney
spears again kevin powderline if i'm the
judge
on kevin yeah where did you think you
were gonna go with this career like
what's what's the end game here what do
you do what are you gonna do
you're a backup dancer where did we go
from here what was your name
can you sing no he can't see all right
what are you gonna do you're gonna be a
backup dancer yeah what are you doing
are you a jabberwocky no i love
jabberwocky me too those guys are crazy
skilled
kevin featherline's not them so if i'm
the judge i'm like what are you what are
you gonna do
you're [ __ ] lucky that this girl was
interested in you she'd be happy with
whatever sum she gives you
how long do backup dancers uh last their
careers
i think it kind of depends depends i
don't imagine too long
they're probably out there in the world
remember remember j-lo's remember she's
dating
the the little dancer little tiny
difference oh yes his name was casper he
had like a whole career afterwards he
was like in movies and stuff
i mean kind of kind of he said i don't
know if he had a whole career
i mean just being a backup dancer he did
he did more than kevin fedor yeah he did
more than kevin fetterline so there's
that
good for him oh 15 to 20 years that's
just for dancers in general but that's
jesus
that's a career i don't imagine there
are too many dancers who make it that
big to the point where
they're doing backup dances for like
ariana grande or j-lo
just imagine beyonce you have to imagine
trying to keep up with her for 15 years
like she's just like a phenom but she
has her squad and i i guess
she keeps the squad tight yeah she keeps
it tight like they can't dance anywhere
else
and they don't need to because she's
amazing yeah yeah
and she also hired uh singers she uh her
backup singers
stay with her for the forum so it's like
a family yeah we can't switch up the
squad all the time yeah
i feel like some people do though yeah i
don't think so just
chin as a band you're not going to want
to switch out people all the time
no it's a freaking nightmare maybe it's
a long time to get together
be a comic you just just roll them c in
the future in every town
i think that my friend uh seems used to
sing for
uh beyonce and backup then she got
opportunity to be on empire so she
turned
down beyonce oh bad move i know now she
regretted me
yeah oh for sure because it's all right
cool story empire just i think they're
on the last season but she wanted to
like break some of the people
like backup singers that want to break
out and just like start their own career
so i couldn't blame her
but at the same time would you leave me
i said to go to empire [ __ ] no
it depends what the role was she had a
great rule
she had a great role and she up a little
bit
off of it is she did she get a spin off
of it
doesn't have a spin off it doesn't
happen well no i'm saying did she get
like
did she like oh she's like well now
she's like
trying to like of course she's
auditioning i think she has a project
coming
up but the fact that she was getting
paid so much money
and she took a risk on herself you can't
for her though yeah yeah
just dance her ass she's bad too she's
beautiful
you can't be a backup dancer beyonce and
be busted oh she's tall gorgeous
i want to bring up i want to put a
business out there she's tall she's
gorgeous she's on the tv show she oh
yeah
yeah empire yeah
uh keandra uh keandra uh
uh anderson i think roger's no
don't even know your homegirl's last
year no
i call her kikido yeah whatever dude no
no her last name
yeah i don't know last name just type in
beyonce uh
backup dancer uh uh
a lot of them that's a lot what did
you get i added all of them in there
that's how you get the switches
i love malik though really good friend
what's your name
we call him
your character on empire you do not know
this girl
no listen i know her listen the reason
why you probably find her instagram
right now because now it's gonna bug me
okay not kendra
james nah nah it's not kendra kendra oh
yeah sonia
hold on i'm about to tell you right now
hold on yeah it's whatever yeah but yo
no no reason why i don't follow her
because she dated my best friend
and he was like bro unfollow her if you
know i'm not following her why are you
keeping a relationship
i was like all right bet uh insecure
match yeah right yeah
yeah she was cool man she was quite like
that she supported all the show but
again what would you do that's a great
question that's a great question okay
let's say
you know yo chappelle's girl no you
break up and they break up and
i was cool with her and he was cool with
her but if chappelle gave me he's like
i'm following her i'm like what are you
12.
malik isn't this one yeah that's my girl
yeah keandra yeah
not your girl i mean that's a girl that
you know of no no literally i could call
her right now
that's my that's my really friend like i
literally she might she's like but you
don't follow her i can't follow because
i respect my man so much that didn't
make sense against jeremiah you can't be
that good of a friend can
what do you mean she's super she comes
to the show every time she's like man
malik winning the next house she support
but at the same time i get my man
i don't i don't if ma if chabell's okay
man i'm full of my girl she's the reason
like
don't know her last name okay whatever i
don't know this is tricky though yeah
but that's a dicey situation
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
and now she knows you don't follow her
she knows i don't follow her but
she knows that yeah she understand i was
telling her the reason why i signed the
dm sometimes like just checking on you
no she wish me happy brother stop it she
comes to the show she's like really
a real friend yeah i don't know you
can't say real good friend because you
don't follow her on instagram
and also you didn't know her last name
okay i don't know how to last your best
no it's not my best friend how long you
know i met her through him no
i don't know three years she was dating
your best friend yes
i thought and that's i thought justin's
your best friend that's my partner
that's my partner yeah
but this is my listen i have him live
now you [ __ ] up right
who's your best friend man i can't have
multiple best friends yeah he can
yeah he said you try you trying to do
this you're trying to fish i have a lot
of best friends thank you yeah
exactly but i'm saying yo but well yeah
i have a myspace top eight
yeah yeah like the the order doesn't
matter it don't matter but as long as
they hand sometimes we go through [ __ ]
depends what lane i'm in you know yeah
you can't just have one best friend
exactly you can like especially it's
like from childhood
yeah but you you but you grow you grown
to make other families you also you're
also growing that's family that's
fantastic
that's true you know what i mean you
also grow a little a little bit apart
but you're still
close you know what i'm saying yeah i
got friends in denver like klopp cody
donovan
where at the time we're in the same
we're doing the same [ __ ] we're running
together like
me and cody came up through mixed
martial arts together me and clap came
up through football together through you
know he helped you get through
college yeah but then that's a family
yeah but then
you know i go over here in my lane i'm
in la now
so i don't see him as much but when we
talk it's it's all good it's all good
yeah
see yeah i'm the same way there's
nothing worse than the needy friend
oh the friend that's like oh how are you
not gonna
fame changed you oh my gosh you know me
friends of mine man you went hollywood
on
me you don't talk to me no more i'm like
what yeah i was like bro what i was
talking i mean
yeah i moved to l.a yeah is that
hollywood first of all you disrespect me
by calling me hollywood because
hollywood is dirty as [ __ ]
it's called holly weird but also i mean
going hollywood would be like
getting on [ __ ] men in black four and
like blowing up next
[ __ ] will smith yeah hollywood's not
like
a torn comic it's like
do you even know what hollywood means
yeah i'm getting an xbox commercial
that's not hot it's not hollywood
i hate that [ __ ] though yeah i get it
all the [ __ ] time but i need to get
rid of my friends all the time
dude i get it a lot yeah it might be
something to look into then they all say
it
yeah oh yeah they all like my girl last
night was like man you going hollywood
you might want to listen to so many
people no
back home people that you used to run
with all the time
you mean when you were drinking and like
doing backflips and [ __ ] yeah yeah
drinking wild turkey and doing
cartwheels but now you're i mean you're
just in a different lane
i'm just not like you don't care but
it's like bro ah listen
i just work differently yeah but i'm not
gonna catch up with you over the phone
yeah i got [ __ ] kids you're not even
a phone person
never yeah not talking about even when
we try to get like like when we're
trying to communicate with him like if
we he's on the road
yeah and he's somewhere and we're not
we're like hey where you at
this [ __ ] won't answer bro it's
jay who is barely on my phone yeah i'm a
real
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro if him and jay is
like
oh jay's together out here next week he
is yeah he's here wednesday through
sunday
my god like he's doing a tour like he's
doing a weekend
yeah he's at la jolla comedy club
yeah just to kick it no we're going to
shoot that thick boy commercial oh yeah
for that this thursday next thursday
sorry next thursday yeah yeah i can't
wait man
yeah i'll be fine i was talking last
night was going over you know what
series that me and him disco well i
discovered now
yeah suits have you seen it dude someone
else talks oh my god
what's good i'm in season one episode
six i love
mike i love that you're into other shows
yeah i can't emphasize enough if it
ain't
love island i'm at the
end of season five and it's like season
six he's caught up yeah he got it he got
everybody's season five signing in and
[ __ ]
yeah i just want to say this if i just
get a quick signature on this water
bottle it'd be great amber
love what you're doing big fan you gotta
sign the bottom of this water bottle
i'll tell my girl though show it up to
the meet and greet yeah i wouldn't
i'll get my book signed when i got it
chinese
let me get a picture man how's the new
relationship
you know what yellowstone ended and then
we got in this way that ended
yeah well there's a season four drop in
the summer
got it but since we finished that series
and then jay got us hooked on love
island
we haven't watched i dude i haven't seen
any other tv besides
sports okay and then love island i watch
you nothing else
damn let's take a little break from the
shenanigans with the boys and keep the
lights on with these commercials
playoffs
we'll talk about playoffs that's right
football playoffs start this weekend
wild card baby and there's no better
place to get in in
all the action with draftkings
sportsbook america's top-rated
sportsbook app
if you haven't checked it out yet it's
really dope there's no better time to
sign up and start cashing in right now
you also got the bcs on monday you got
the wild card this weekend saturday and
sunday
you got nba popping all right
everything's going on right now you got
ufc coming up next week
start making money watching your
favorite sports with draftkings
sportsbook app right now
and to celebrate the most exciting time
of the football season
draftkings has given you the chance to
double your money all it takes is one
touchdown to be scored during saturday's
football games
that's right once you opt in place your
bet all you have to do is sit back and
wait for a touchdown
while we're all excited for football
let's not forget 2021 basketball season
has kicked off
so head to the app right now check out
all the draftking daily odds boost
draftkings is safe secure reliable make
it easy for you to deposit withdraw your
money
when you want download that top-rated
draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code fighter when you sign
up to have a shot at doubling your money
if a touchdown is scored in one of the
saturdays football games
that's code fighter for new players to
get a shot at doubling their money for
limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook must be 21 or older new
jersey
indiana pennsylvania only restrictions
apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling prom
question mark call 1-800 gambler or in
indiana
1-809 with it remember download the
draftking sports
app promo code fighter so i dude i
haven't seen
any other tv besides sports okay and
then love island i watch you nothing
else
damn because i don't watch a lot of tv
so
like kids go to bed at like 7 30.
no then i'll get two hours so i get two
episodes in and then i go to bed
damn in the morning i might see some but
it's off to the runnings with the kids i
barely see any tv i don't listen to me
the only time i listen to music is in
the green room on the road i listen to
podcasts or books on twitter
violent super fan over here right that's
crazy dude i love it
he brings up
on his they'll make you want to get in
shape though because all the boys are
shredded and there's a new kid who kind
of looks like justin bieber
uh older brother if you got beat with a
bat he's in season he's in season six
and he looks a little bit like weaver
yeah he does i know
and my girl's like god his body's not
great i was like better than mine [ __ ]
yeah like it's not bad no i mean he's
not shredded
that meme you posted about the body oh
my god
how [ __ ] funny there he is here
where's one that's oh that guy's
got a kid that's big legs in the middle
that's muscle that's macho man randy
savage legs in the middle
relieve her alone no i love her she's
about she's one of my favorite on the
show
the blonde scene yeah she is real i look
like yeah she's dope ellen the blonde
singer's uh probably my favorite though
the blind singer i don't know that's
something
that it's not this season it's always
weird when you see a seas you haven't
seen before like who the [ __ ] are those
that's the yeah that's that's the one
yes i got in the middle is great okay
i like that little guy in the far left
uh nas is fantastic he's good
oh yeah does he find that he gets friend
zone all the time he finds love
yeah the producers are great because
they bring in a girl for him
really and they just hit it they're like
one in the same but she's serious yeah
you know whose attitude i don't like
bottom right oh bro
i can't stand i can't stand oh my god
attitude
and she has so many followers you know
you know who else drives me nuts is the
black girl in the very back
uh right here yeah yeah see yeah where
chinzero is
yeah her oh she does i think she's
probably the prettiest one her the
blonde singer with blue eyes but
she was going out with this other guy
like right the guy who's going out with
uh
teeth teeth yeah yeah connor yeah yeah
but that yeah
no lie i don't want to ruin it for
anybody all right yeah yeah but then
i don't think a lot of people watch it
besides you but go ahead island
wrong show is [ __ ] huge i don't know
if too many people within this fan base
yeah yeah demographics
a lot of people don't know our
demographic yet not maybe not in america
no it's in america it's probably huge
the american
uh yeah when i was in college that's all
anyone would watch oh
you guys love everybody yeah everyone in
the theater department everyone oh wow
wouldn't talk about love island you come
into class you and your professor is the
usa one good
uh no uh they watch the uk one over at
usc like everybody watching
so yeah it's busy it's huge that's why
they have so many uh instagram followers
because it's like
they blow up and all of them get plastic
surgery when they get off because they
have so many oh follow and you just well
they read
the comments and you're like
their chins get fixed like if you look
at the twins on the show
and in comparison to now like bad
completely different
yeah when they were on those sylvester
stallone eyes they're like all droopy
and then
they're like way better adrian
[Music]
the old
oh damn that was it when they were
younger them girls had some work
they best bodies on the show oh bodies
the [ __ ] but yeah if you look at their
instagram now
completely different what are their
names uh jen
and eve eve
is it jen and ever are they doing a
season set i'm sure that show [ __ ]
yeah jessica season seven i think
jessica got a
boyfriend whoa big dude yeah yeah it's
crazy
yeah look at him now whoa yeah she
crazy dog crazy big hold on hold on hold
on go click on our picture again
no no no no no no did you go in there
and go to eve the other one
so you see her eve comment you see eve
her sister
go to her as well the baddest one i
think she's way better he's better
yeah she filled in i like her
uh take it easy okay look at that look
at that oh
no just so good i like that oh wow yeah
they got some work done and i'm not mad
at you you're not mad at it right to
pretend that that
stuff doesn't improve oh a hundred
percent
i'm all for it if you wanted to kylie
jenner holly jr god
damn yeah i'm lying take it take it off
take it let's take it off get it
come on skip super body day but when the
makeup's off do they
do they still look fine hell no uh a lot
a lot of them do yeah you've never seen
kylie without makeup
like she you know she looks you've seen
kylie some girls i did see what i'm
making what does she look like without
makeup uh
i think she looks all right well a lot
of those girls then like
every episode of the night they show
them taking their makeup off
and some don't like this oh from the
show yeah some don't look that's before
surgery
though i mean something probably going
to the show surgery
oh oh i mean that can't be now is it
yeah that's normal oh wow that's
absolutely normal when you take off your
makeup
they go back to there it's kind of like
12 o'clock when cinderella
loses that heel and she goes back to the
regular yeah damn she's so bad with
makeup
that's why i think contouring the left
her face looks like mine
oh
so what you're saying is you're a bad
she's a bad [ __ ] with makeup yeah i bet
travis scott was like what the
[ __ ] no but hold on
it it's just oh my god the way she is
that's not real she's cute there
no she'll have freckles i think that was
when she was younger and she
had acne and stuff what did she look
like when she was younger right
that's when she was younger that's when
she was younger now 2015 so she was like
19
18 in this oh she had no lips no no
i think when she was like 17 18 she
started getting lip fillers
damn she's turning she's starting to
look like
mom a good good for hers but like
knowing what do you think
yeah i was about to say knowing
awareness she knew she didn't have any
lips she bought something
she's worth a billion dollars exactly is
she really worth the bill yes yeah
really
forbes listed her as a billionaire she
ain't even she's not even 21 is she
she might just she just turned 21 maybe
like
the last few months or like a year she
was born 21 22 now
either way she's young she's young all
right her best friend is way better
oh she's 23 never mind she's 23 yeah oh
that's still young ass no
yeah it's still yeah that's still very
young for a billionaire shutting down
the kardashian show this is their last
last season
they have something going on on hulu
though they announced it a few weeks the
family does
yeah you think they're [ __ ] sick of
the cameras like how much money they
might be doing something else
besides a reality yeah like falling
around 24 7. it must i mean what are
they
they were like were they the first
family that that like followed were
followed around like that
or was it the osborne i feel like the
osborne's lost ones were first right
yeah i think osborne's that's the first
one
that was the first like family that was
like followed up who was first though
you know who uh came up with kardashian
concept ryan seacrest
uh he's that's why he's so rich because
they were on an american idol or what
no he he knew that he knew uh
who that's an old [ __ ]
like the first big one though you know
what i'm saying not the very first
uh black and white one remember the
hogan's had one
but i think that was after the awesome i
actually dug the whole you know what
just about the hogan's one is the
the not brook uh hulk hogan and his wife
they were devoting it
where they were separated but just for
the show that if while they film they
would act like they're together
because they wanted the show to do well
damn [ __ ] making money off of it
yes i remember harassing a good show
yeah
that was big like back in like the 2000s
like that was you have your own reality
reality
tv show with your family oh i loved uh
fantasia um
what runs house runs
oh yeah that was good too yeah that was
a good one that was like that and he had
those batty daughters
come on they still uh
you know uh one married uh damian wayne
uh the older one oh really yeah
the younger the vanessa vanessa yeah
that was a good show
and then t.i had his show too oh yeah
you had me watching in nashville no
because they got separated
they were fighting on it oh t.i love and
hip hop oh
hip-hop little scrambling hip-hop
hip-hop
yo it is great new york's good too
atlanta is where they pop off is that
the one i was watching
where they got the fight yeah that's
where cardi b came from oh yeah wait she
she came from new york right new york
yeah gosh
or reality shows could you do it no [ __ ]
no right
couldn't do it couldn't do it that would
drive me especially now no it drive me
nuts
right and then it just seems fake too
like
like there's no way those the
kardashians are real on there and a lot
of it's
you know scripted yeah yeah and then
it's like you come up with beefs
within the family and you're shooting
all [ __ ] day
uh 24 7. i always thought are they
shooting 24 7 yeah
i always thought like when they go to
these restaurants and then you see
people in the background are those real
people
i didn't know that as a young i was like
yo why are they not saying anything
like they literally having like
conversations the kardashians in public
and they're just like if you just like
watch i love watching movies to see like
background actors to like get like
something
yeah yeah yeah yeah you'll see them like
that
like no
ain't nobody know who you
from are actress is the funniest it is
the funniest [ __ ] to watch
especially like you gotta get the ones
like closer to the camera because
they'll have like a
casual conversation say like kim right
there and then you just say what talking
it's like it's usually the guy like here
yeah
just make sure they're in the shot so
funny though but yeah oh how about your
boy won the heisman last night
that uh smith from alabama we called it
yeah kind of i thought i thought they
were gonna give it to homeboy from
clemson
nah why are you talking about trevor
wallace yeah he was the big favorite
going into the year
bro he didn't play enough but no no and
but it's rare a guy
that's not a quarterback the last time a
wide receiver was in
was 1997.
why mike told you yeah yeah don't forget
about it
how about the three that aren't
quarterbacks all come from alabama yeah
uh henry for that badass running back
for the titans yeah
uh mark ingram mark he was all right who
was on the same race
yeah he's all right it was like 91 was
the last time a
wide receiver or that's been howard wow
dog you know what sucked
imagine imagine so it's the most like
exclusive club in all of sports
the heisman dude i mean there's one a
year there's one
you have something for basketball like
that yeah but it's not a bit that
as big of a deal the heisman's such a
big deal imagine being those four kids
and it's like the pinnacle of your
career
and you're on zoom because usually it's
a big [ __ ] event
no if all the alumni come out it's a
huge award
like you're in tuxedos i was what i felt
so bad for those kids
wait they weren't oh yeah they're all at
home it's on
zumbro well imagine people remember the
draft this year
horrible yeah they they were all at home
radio city new york like you're in your
[ __ ] sunday best
you got tailored suits you're walking
the red carpet your family's there yeah
it's
your moment your moment you've been
working your entire life for it it's on
zoom
yeah yeah i think and his and his
earpiece is [ __ ] up they're like the
winner
of the 2020 eisman trophy winner
smith and then you see him he's all
huh and all of them are like i'm gonna
try to put it here and he's like
i won me really and then he's like and
there's just no ikai pizza
very cool thank you it's so weird
it was such a remember that sucks i
think that's the
i think that's the world we live in
hopefully we get out of it but we'll get
out of it yeah so
so someone that gets the heisman are
they usually he's taking off
he has to be top three he has to be
tight but he goes to miami are you gonna
cut my question
i'm sorry i'm sorry i apologize i just
thought about it because we was talking
about like trevor wallace and then we
got my
boy from ohio state and then you call
that guy trevor wallace one more time
i'm sorry
trevor lawrence look at i knew that i'm
so sorry i'm sorry
that's good trevor lawrence yes you got
justin fields one and two
and then smith that's what i'm saying so
i think you need to go three because two
i need someone to throw i was just about
to say that or they or they draft that
big ass
attack from oregon who what a big tackle
he
uh decided to play this year but he's a
mom oh yeah
i was you about it yeah that was my
question yeah so someone that gets the
heisman
yes um that's you that's usually a
person that's going on
to the nfl oh yeah correct every single
one right now there's been a few who
state well no no they don't want to like
a sophomore junior might win and they
there's been guys that stayed like tim
tebow almost won it twice
crazy you can do that oh yeah like he
won i think as a soccer junior and then
he
then he finished like second the
following year but there's some guys who
almost win it twice does the is dion
sanders a heisman
no no no no but he was a beast though no
he was a beast though i like that guy
dion sanders yeah yeah his son his son
you know what about ochocinco
what about him no he wasn't no [ __ ] no
he wasn't [ __ ] well
it's not that he wasn't [ __ ] in college
he just too no he played at tennessee
chattanooga
ain't nobody won the heisman attention
said nobody and then and then you boy
from a badass school no big time school
like big time ballers but then there's
like guys like danny warfall
or like eric crouch who they win the
heisman because they're the best college
player and then
they get drafted late what about michael
irving no dude
damn mike is his husband are you
listening
god damn you just shouting out david
there's usually a lot of pressure on him
usually heisman besides henry usually
the heisman winners aren't very good cam
newton
okay congratulations there you go there
we go now now i wanna i wanna bring up
the argument real quick when we get off
sports
um i believe derek henry is the mvp
now i know you're gonna say aaron
rodgers i know you're probably gonna say
patrick will holmes
but let's just understand tennessee won
11 games
with derek henry on his but he carried
that team for sure okay
so look at the yards and he's been doing
a consecutive conference
good conference in uh tennessee right 11
games on his back
now patrick mahomes what do you he has
weapons around for sure okay aaron
rodgers you can say you don't have any
rep
on his weapon oh okay well let's say he
has weapons around him and he's been
doing it listen
we didn't expect this year from aaron
rodgers but with derek henry
non-quarterback you can't tell me anyone
who's balling like that so i think like
he's the most valuable player
to that team because they'd be well done
green baby dog [ __ ] too yeah but in that
kid they drafted that that youngster
there are you talking about from uh uh
utah um the black guy yeah
go and put him in let me know my game
love but but but
sure if i can't give you that but you
know but you know i'm just
so you're saying you'll give it to
rogers i give it to hearing
i can say i listen whoever wins it i
won't be mad at if if rogers
henry or mahomes wins it you get all
homes every year yeah yeah he's such a
bullet i mean but listen but again
put in mahone's backup let me know how
many games they went you think they went
29 out of 28.
again it's sorry 20 20 but but you also
got to credit
the system you don't think andy reid
have a has a system in place for that
team that squat
he's a genius we already seen he did it
with donald vicki and nab no they didn't
change john mcnabb as good as patrick
mahomes no but i'm not even close
look at the numbers but uh look at kc
before
my homeschool yeah let's look at the
[ __ ] okay they were [ __ ] but listen what
about the
the alex smith is he he was he was
winning
mvp caliber but he was winning with alex
yeah but mvp and
the best team in the league before
before tennessee what was what was
before derek henry what was tennessee
you could say that same argument
you had that same argument before uh
derek henry got there what was tennessee
a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] so you mean to tell me this
guy did it back to back years so they
they were all right with mariota some of
those years all right
okay they're only 11 and five it's not
like they're the best team in the league
okay but last year they might get past
this wild card round
they upset they did last year i know
that's last year we're talking this year
but he's doing it we'll see but that's
why but that that's i think it did they
franchise
no yeah they frantic franchise they
gotta pay
and he did that but the leagues don't
because running backs they turn old
overnight
and you can get that many carries in
that wear and tear wear and tear and you
don't think he deserves his money and
he's the interview
i think they should pay him yeah okay
let's go let's get him yeah
again i'm not mad if if he gets it at
all okay
mahomes rogers or henry are those are
the mom we all
that's the three listen three we all can
agree mahomes can win it every year he
suffers from lebron james
lebron james can win the mvp every year
okay and they'll give it to him which is
crazy all right my homes can't get get
it every season because he's that good
but i'm talking about this year
rogers and derrick henry rogers we
didn't know he was
well we expected him to do this but he's
just like killing right now super bowl
super balling but derek henry we did not
know
he was going to no he fall out last year
but 8th eighth
only eight running backs right for 2 000
yards
back-to-back you think that would win
him the mvp because only eight nights
and listen rodgers is having a great
year but is it like a historical season
nah but come on man that's all i'm
saying mvp they don't even go like this
that's all i'm saying okay we get off
we'll see man all right
oh how how about your boy ryan garcia
going after tank
are you telling me that's a bad idea
what are you doing is he is he still
pressing that yeah bro he said two
rounds not only is he pressing it he's
talking [ __ ]
really bro i had to i i and then he and
then he's like either tank or lopez like
bro
i don't know if you want that lopez uh
lopez
take over take over uh lomachenko yeah
monster
yeah yeah i agree but i think that and i
talked to my homie closely
he was like bro take a he's serious
about like [ __ ] up ryan garcia
are you so tank would do it but but i'm
sure but yeah but i don't think golden
boy i don't think other boy
but you close with showtime what did you
i mean i'll find out more today because
i do that mike tyson food truck and
ryan garcia is there before me so i'm
gonna talk to him okay
is he but i think that's the fight he
wants that's why you want tank
tank wants to fight too i don't know i
don't feel like he wants it i feel like
it's not smart
so okay breaking down the ufc terms so
like
what that well because i'm trying to
understand like
why it would be like so like sugar shawn
o'malley you know who that is yeah yeah
it'd be like giving him the champ right
now like damn dogs
let's let them slow your roll yeah
there's no reason to fight right now
that's what that's what she does
like just being like why can't he have
it wasn't like it wasn't a
you didn't pass with flying i was just
about to say you showed a lot of heart
and grit
and then wary of a champion but if the
tank lands that [ __ ]
you know that match and listen or lopez
nope for that matter lopez would do
cracks let's just put lopez out of this
situation because he's on a different
notice how nobody's calling lopez out
because he's a bad [ __ ] tank one
kind of no one's really calling lopez
would that be a fight
and lopez yeah i think tank would get
him no no wouldn't it be possible
they're gonna have to fight but would it
be but also lopez is talking about
moving up to 140
because he's the top dog and again he
can't sustain that weight he's a big
dude
he's got a lot for him there it's not
but what the 140 division is kind of
quiet anyway so i don't see why he will
move up
just as fast you got tank right here you
got ryan garcia you got uh
shakur stevenson can move up he's 126.
126 130 then 135
you have um who else young uh machinko
you still haven't
uh haney oh devin haney yeah now here's
the thing about devin hayne
i don't see haney and ryan garcia fight
both young up-and-comers
you know danny uh uh he beat uh ryan
garcia twice in amateur amateurs yeah
yeah
oh yeah he's talked about that yeah no
no there's different levels and also i
think that ryan garcia
once he develops he is so much he's
gonna be a monster he has to develop
first yeah
he he doesn't have a jab he's so if he's
so if he took that fight that would
mess up a lot for him if he lost if he
were before a tank yeah
and he gets like starched yeah and and a
lot of people believe he'll get starts
now
that's what i'm saying i don't think
he'll fight but i think he wants it
because
he's like fighting or maybe he's just
maybe he's just putting the energy out
there no i think he's going so hard in
the paint though i know oh really yeah
it's it's like going harder in the paint
also understanding where you are
he's believing that hype train he's like
i'm the best ever like i'm right now
he's like
two rounds anytime he says two rounds
and they make a flyer of both of them
like
like you know yeah and there's like talk
is cheap like yo listen this guy really
believes he can beat tank
honestly so his fans are gonna back him
up oh yeah oh [ __ ]
and now he's fans are young too so they
don't yeah they don't know i don't know
what he's signing up for
that's a death wish but also i don't i
hope we talked to sins to that young kid
i like him but like okay so say
damn could they possibly give him that
fight though oh
it's on the table yeah it's it's that or
yeah it's on the table
but the wbc uh ordered uh uh devin and
um
uh lope ryan garcia next because he
they're both they both
should do so it's interim champions
meaning like both of them
share the same bills i'm saying is there
someone up there that would be like hey
you're not writing this is a [ __ ] show
yeah
it's too many it's way too many bells
anytime they're they both
hold the belt for the same thing that's
right wbc
wbo uh lopez call us and ufc
they wouldn't they'd be like no no
you're not doing that fight well yeah
it's rare you'd have to climb like
you're not gonna just go from
you know a luke campbell caliber guy to
[ __ ]
tank no yeah but yeah man i i hope the
young kid ryan garcia like
you know slowest tempo i think oscar de
la hoya
yeah but that's who honestly who does
golden boy have other than oscar de la
hoya i mean uh ryan garcia
no that's that's the boy's love so why
would you shoot your star
like your star power out there against
these they're idiots okay that's right
he said he uh did he tweet like no he's
not ready yet yeah
but again we'll see if your fighter want
it you can like all right man
all right like he tell us he gives us
advice he's like man
you can do what you want but i'm telling
you chill and it is
naturally we're like nah man it'll come
down to money though
it's a lot of money on that table
japan's what it is yeah
get that jab ryan garcia i hope you get
one yeah we'll see oh he don't have a
jab
nah hell no he stands two listen he got
starched in that second round
and if luke campbell was a killer like
uh like tank that's trouble
oh got it yeah now you passed your first
test young kid that's great you got a
belt
chill out go back to the gym of canelo
learn some stuff
learn like oh i got caught with his
overhand left learn from that but don't
go out there
don't go after a monster like that man
that's all i'm saying we'll see
all right what do you got cat okay
let's see you guys covered some of it
already yeah so we talked about this kim
kardashian
and then we talked about no one knows
for sure though what do you mean
nothing's final it's all hearsay yeah
it's all hearsay but
we've kind of been hearing this for a
while
that's true yeah you guys pretty much
talked about this already it's only what
the media tells us right so we don't
know
yeah i want to go i want to know where
does kim go from here
right she went from all the athletes in
the back but all the rappers and
athletes right you think it's time to
try a white guy
i was alluding i was a loser struck out
a few times
black man do you think you'd give a
white man a chance at this point
or armenian army
i was alluding to that but it's
obviously not working
it's just not the right really calling
it like it is just not
right well she did have a white guy the
guy who played for the nets and he was
an [ __ ]
oh no he wasn't white he was mixed chris
humphreys
well he's stuck in the middle yeah
they even had a wedding and [ __ ] look oh
damien these are people assuming who
she's going to date
no no no oh yeah ray j was
the first one no no no nick cannon was
whoa
what the hell oh cincinnati's finest
let's go
dude that was a hot second oh it was
yeah look at her
keep going [ __ ]
kim kardashian before ray j yeah oh he
was before
like the one of the first guys she's
ever dated wow she came back to him
i remember that
because she's also armenian yeah yeah
they're bothering me she's super
what brazilian wife is armenian yeah
current wife she looks just like him
yeah
she boxes bro uh she goes to the gym
that would be i train that
go to a boxing video chin she got hands
yeah she's super super right there look
at that yeah they have a cute kid too
man
i think a few of them right yeah she's
got a few kids with them oh
you should see man shout out to that man
wife now
she's a beast yeah she'll be with jimmy
uh this is over there uh
cbc boxes
[Laughter]
oh that's a girl said that i think she's
a boxer right yeah it looks like it she
actually oh oh shoot
dang okay there's some other pictures of
her yeah hello
cop oh she's a cop where's that acting
oh damn i'm not a real clown oh okay
okay wait he
no haters are gonna say i'm not a real
cop hater
oh [ __ ] so she might be a cop oh she's a
cop that's a box
not bad looking either
just watch it
yeah she's pretty man oh yeah sure
i'll take that comment back that jab was
[ __ ] what's your box you're right
girl that just that's a [ __ ] solid
jab
what is this i don't know i never been
cornejo oh that's her
all right that's it yeah but she's a
shout out to ray j's girl though yeah
shout out to that's what i mean no i
oh christian ronaldo she dated him
he would fly her out and then he kind of
big-timed her
really yeah she was like a booty call
for cristiano how big
miles austin i remember that cowboy
who's that uh he played a wide receiver
for the dallas cowboys okay
who was that who's that michael capoon
oh my god i liked him as a kid
he was like sort of asian didn't he yeah
he's been like that's so raven right
yeah that's so rare he was
growing up what's he do now though i
don't know
when they were like real young because
that doesn't count
he's still so fine god damn he's fine
yeah
still yeah i think he's fine interesting
i told him he's actually really good
looking he's in scorpion kingdom yeah
he's happy
you know he's half what he's filipino
and white yeah that's he was in power
rangers
well that might be him now oh he's so
cute
oh damn
chin said take it easy he was in scorpio
it's like it's a baby with the rock man
how
was uh that was he's like a halle berry
x there it is yeah yeah that scarf is
intense
keep going he's at the lakers again
that's the one
yeah so weird it was he was on he was
getting they had they had a full-on
wedding right oh yeah they had a huge
wedding for
a 72 day marriage and then he got it
he got booed nonstop every time he went
in the games really yeah he did it yeah
he came for this to the sons for a hot
second is it just because he
was with kim kardashian you just get
booed every time you touch the ball you
get booed
yeah oh that's so sad and a lot of this
he wasn't a great player so it was like
yeah man i'm trying to get some work is
he still playing or not no i don't think
so
no he said like a lot of his teammates
didn't like him like because when he
showed up with kim
cameras everywhere like man goddamn oh
just bring a lot of
unwanted attention yeah yeah because
they made a whole like
series out of their wedding right i
think so yeah
yeah yeah that was a weird one
what is he doing now he's probably still
playing no
tv shows he oh he's on a tv show
but probably the reality no just the
kardashians yes he's not an actor
so he doesn't play more oh he does 2017
was last year
oh probably took his money and invested
it
damn he played for everybody yeah
personal life national team career what
is that
honorable 2002. oh no he's uh he
invested in real estate and owned his uh
restaurant in minnesota
good for him congrats there you go yeah
invest your money man he can only go up
i'm learning
so kim has been with some wives she got
a catalogue
asians a lot of blacks
because filipinos are mixed with
spaniards already so it's like
half of that yeah so you're kind of like
yeah divine like jokoy jokoy is half
yeah oh wow looks super asian does he
really he has green eyes
that guy just looked like a mexican
that's fair chill on scorpion king man
i know yeah
that's not how i describe that man she's
like he's fun it's fine you don't like
asian guys
well yeah uh we talked about this one
too
um dr dre uh recently posted on
instagram that he is recovering from his
brain aneurysm they don't look like he's
okay
uh he's recovering now they're trying to
figure out what caused the brain
aneurysm divorce yeah
i agree my mom said the same stress
stress yeah dude and you know
only 50 percent of people survive a
brain aneurysm really 50
one and two survive yeah so it's bad
like that's a bad one
it's not uh it's not good no thank god
he's all right though
yeah yeah high blood pressure
schmuck strike robbing him when he blows
you now that's the
crazy thing about that like do you think
the ex-wife
did something like that like he has 150
175 million dollars in cash in his house
of course you're going to go in there
and try to get a house i don't think she
met do they get in the house
no no they tried because they didn't
they joined him
pulled up but he lives in brentwood they
caught these four dudes
right there there you go they're all
caught
yeah he probably told him to go to my
house
who said that i'm saying like the cops
or whatever he told doctor
probably told him i feel like he
probably has private security you know
and like alarm systems and all that
stuff
everything it's doctor drake i think dr
jay woke up out of his home was like go
to my house
i'm joining for 48 chappelle
go to my house you said he's he's
[Laughter]
get to my house 175 million
all he cares about is wait so his wife
shouted that out while he was
no hospital oh no what i'm saying going
through the of course you
they're going through like the the
custody stuff in the mud the divorce and
she said it
and then the outlets picked it up she
got on twitter like hey he's in the
hospital there's a hundred
465 million at his house i'm surprised
just saying
just say hashtag good luck hashtag
security code
join my only fans account for the
address i'm saying i'm surprised they
catch her over there like hold on now
and that's their daughter how many kids
i believe she lives in a different home
she lives in their malibu home yeah his
daughter's pop
well his ex-wife is i don't know what's
his face yeah because she hasn't
she is
yeah yeah she looks like a superhero
that chin that chin looked like uh
aquaman's chin no
seriously these are good qualities
though hey young she was a baby
that's not her young is it it is oh okay
[Music]
yeah dr dre a legend man yeah that
should go right
now is that her that's her different
hair
i think she always shirts so intense
mother [ __ ]
mother mother [ __ ] um
she should always keep her black hair
though i don't like now that blonde
looks cool you think so
yeah i know man strong with
strong fans
oh she's tied up on the teddy oh yeah
that's it you got a real one yeah you
got a street one if they got tied
up on the titties tyreese got the same
tattoo on his belly belly button though
oh no the god smack tattoo on the belly
button yeah some people will get that
reference yeah some people get that
that's tyrese's belly button
get that mtv spring break got smacked
oh
[Music]
his tattoos look like you went to the
tattoo shop you know they just have the
random tattoos on the walls
i'll take that i'll take that oh yeah
like sure
give me the pamela anderson yeah
we can't be around that you can't be
around
like a metal type of thing back then
yeah back then it was like a middle yeah
are you also yeah if you're the lead
singer of creed
he pissed off oh yeah
dude no she fell did your piercings
close up or can you put one back in
because
that one i took mine out because uh i
was eating subway one day and i bit the
ring and i [ __ ] snatched it out like
no nothing screams i'm a white guy on
the inside like a black
guy with a tattooed lip like that
i just look at him like yeah yeah that's
cool yeah
that's cool yeah you listen to god's man
that's one of them you're a rob zombie
fan
that's cool you showed up because it's
right there that's a strong
hurt no i didn't hurt it didn't hurt
when you got it done
did you have you you look dope with a
nose piercing everything about that
no oh that should be like what like here
yeah [ __ ] yeah
with like a little hoop like the old
school wait what the [ __ ] i think no
no no no no again again no not here not
the ball
i think just a little hoop like a tube
i feel like everyone you talk to about
face piercings you always try to talk
someone into a nose ring
yeah what the [ __ ] have you done a cat
no oh i'd be sick
i think you're trying to i tried talking
my girl into it and she got oh you said
something like that yeah something like
that would be cool on chappelle
lenny kravis that was this was too much
too much
yeah he has his dick pierced chris brown
does it look that could be me if i got
my [ __ ] together
that could be me if i ever figured out
what look i want to go
[Laughter]
friend who's a guy we did it together
i'm looking back looking back i know i'm
like oh that that
whatever piercer thought for sure
because we were kind of like oh you can
do it
oh
did the tongue hurt it hurt but it
healed up but then it never felt right
even that
never felt like it ever fully healed
yeah
did he go with you every time you y'all
got a piercing do you go with you no
we we actually got a piercing gun once
what i don't know i don't know how we
got it but
like you know years ago yeah so we were
just taking just pierce on ears
i went crazy i did all this like boomer
here you were lost
i got i got it i thought it was cool was
this when you before or after you lost
your weight
after after so that's why i was like
more confident i was like
yeah that's good damn that's raising any
tattoos
i know piercings go to tattoos i'm gonna
be getting tattoos because i've always
wanted tattoos
i could see you with a quail fish on
your own i want one on the neck i want
one on the neck too now i keep telling
you you should do it
and my girl wants me to get like the
wings that wrap around i love neckties i
want to get a bird one on the neck too
i'm trying to come on just like like a
spear or something i'm talking about
my girl wants me the whole thing yeah on
the neck that wrap around
like you can see it on the side here
okay guys you're so all behind
damn that's gonna hurt you know who has
like sick ass tattoos
he's a model i follow him because of his
tattoos
oh i think i know what you're talking
about who who is elijah this guy steven
james
i've never heard of them you never seen
this guy is he on love island
no it looks like
yeah still all your [ __ ] girls damn
the neck one's not as good but his
other tattoos are sick well he got it
really well he's got he's got some dope
ones yeah
what rolex is that i don't know
that's my submariner the same as mine i
thought i had it on
so he has a skull yeah on the head too
yeah that's just that's that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
a jew he has the hebrew you'll be real
set you know to do that stuff
well he's a model though he's a model
yeah model yeah you got to go crazy
if you want to be a model [ __ ] dude
remember that dude that became a model
off his mug shot i talked about jordan
meeks jeremy
jeremy and he married a baddie yeah
no he was married when he was in jail he
had a girl and they had a kid and then
when he got out he started
dating the heiress to topshop yep no
the guy who found topped up her daughter
i mean his daughter is currently dating
jeremy
yeah is he on instagram really yes he is
he
yeah there was like a huge scandal about
it because
his wife at that time found out on
instagram
through photos like everyone else dating
yeah like he broke up with her in that
way on instagram
i don't see it now he got out of prison
i don't see all the hype
his bug shot was good yeah i don't know
yeah he's bodied up yeah he's killed a
good [ __ ] dude
crush on life yeah okay oh yeah he would
crush on love island he's a good looking
dude
i mean nothing crazy though that other
dude who looked like me if i got my [ __ ]
together
wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa whoop
find his wife uh jerry mix wife all
right i think
oh is that his wife no no that's a beast
but not big films though it's his eyes
said wife yeah i thought it i thought it
was
right or done yeah this one like clay
green ooh and when his ex-wife filed for
divorce and they finally signed all the
papers she had a club promotion where
she was doing
like a divorce party she get money
yeah so she's making money that's
the top shop
[Music]
brendan what oh what's wrong she looks
not bad
oh no that's cool we also
we all thinking that let's just not say
it the air is out there
let's not say let's just say yeah some
kind of restraint yeah yeah if she
wasn't
let's just have some time your kids are
gonna have piercing blue eyes
oh yeah yeah for sure for sure
let's let's let's let's come tell me
don't tell me
i was like she wasn't a billionaire
house of commons
i don't think so man why let me look at
the calendar fully booked
good for them for figuring out what's
what is it what does that look like
though
let's see if he [ __ ] up wife x
oh she's seems like he's zombie g let's
see he's the opposite that's what he's
the opposite of kim kardashian but she
she hides behind filters you gotta get
the natural pictures god
oh you know you [ __ ] up right so you
saw that [ __ ]
god you know you didn't you know you
[ __ ]
you said you said you said you bought
them you said you like bad [ __ ]
and i
he didn't chase the money he did check
god she's got money
oh his ex right now yeah i don't i mean
no that's not like not like
homegirl now yeah she got a lot of
followers she's not she she's bad yeah
she's joined up
she was with him during prison and she
verified too
let me see not great
definitely more our speed than the other
girl yeah
heavy on eyebrows i think jay would like
the other girl proper english yeah like
he said sure
oh is she english yeah ooh that makes
her a little top shop yeah for me yeah
that makes it
oh because she's top chef top shop
that's a uk based
clothing brand oh they're at the grove i
shop when i need suits
all right well good for him all right
well yeah
what is love chappelle love his tight
love his gangster you know what's even
tyler in love
no money according to him i thought
you're going to say them cheekbones
so there is uh a video that went viral
on tick tock it's kind of a new thing
that i've been seeing where
people who work at gas stations or
liquor stores will record them having
interactions with
their like regulars and this guy started
to record
a homeless man who would come in and try
to buy like food cigarettes and stuff
uh a lot of his fans ended up falling in
love with this guy because he just
seemed like he had a really positive
attitude down on his luck
and this is the video that went viral go
all the way down
all the way down
this one yeah so like tick-tockers would
uh set up cash apps and they'd
uh fans would send money to give to this
homeless man so we'd give them like 100
200 based off of donations just help him
get an id
a used phone so he kind of get his life
back on track
and this is him saying that he needed i
believe 200
to get a pair of glasses from walmart
because he couldn't see
and so he's being given five hundred
dollars and he starts crying it's just a
feel-good video
what are you trying to get some glasses
yeah that's what i'm doing i can't see
but thanks for you
you it wasn't for you man i love you a
lot don't you get me on the right track
i have a little bit of money everybody
started yeah i've already started uh
yes how much how much you make today
eleven dollars you made eleven dollars
seven dollars i bought a
bunch of food i yes i'm starting bus
because
so how much your glasses cost about 150
dollars at walmart
150 dollars at walmart yeah yes you got
to watch
150 windows yes i do guys we're gonna
stop
don't stop now i'm gonna get that keep
on going until i get my job and a house
how about this boom five hundred dollars
for you go get a room go get your house
and
tomorrow i'm gonna get my glasses i am
going to be a [ __ ]
god
[Music]
oh my god and that was viewed
on the original account 13.
what do we think that he's using that
five hundred dollars for all that stuff
do we not think he's gonna turn that 500
some drug money no i think he's gonna
get glasses i think
i think 150 that will go to classes what
happens the other money
because that's that's where i get dicey
with homeless people well you can't give
them to you so much
yeah you give them so much come on
here's a thousands like gregor did two
days ago
also you can catch a vibe yeah you can
kind of figure it out yeah you can see
someone that's just genuinely yeah he
seems
pretty genuine yeah this money changed
people
well remember 150 that's going to hit so
he can glasses and
what happened to the other that's what
i'm that's where i get dicey with it
like
if he has a drug problem you're just
enabling him yeah yeah you have 350
dollars he doesn't look like he cracked
down right no
no no i'm just i'm just saying yeah i'm
just saying like
like when you see a lot of those dudes
on the side of the road who have the
signs you're like uh
i give you money you're just gonna it's
just gonna enable your drug habit
sometimes yeah you can really tell yeah
that one i can't i need to see more
videos
how do you guys feel about um this is
just my personal opinion but how do you
guys feel about people filming
themselves doing
good deeds like that it turns out well
right because people want to contribute
but i always feel like that's weird like
i mean i think it's everyone's
do what you want yeah with your your
whatever you want to do like i'd say
don't film it
yeah just do it just do it but then i
guess he got in recognition so but also
at the same time when you look at like
everything that is like put out on the
news you never really see stuff like
this that's
so negative so like that's what i mean
what's like you do you know what uh
barstool's doing
have you ever it yeah we talked about it
on king the sting and
we actually donated to it five thousand
dollars yeah barstool
they're trying to save small businesses
so they've raised like 12 million
dollars i think it's 17 or 18 million is
it up to 18 million now
so they have all these businesses send
in that they need help they have to
prove that they're successful before
everything and then they save them for a
few months that's what i'm saying like
you're saving the small business
no no because the government's not doing
it so the people have to come up with
creative ideas to [ __ ] get it done
but i used to i used to be like you chin
i i
used to think it was like weird to like
film but but that but like now it's like
you know what no it's it's not bad i
mean people need to see
some type of light because there's so
much that's just thrown out there man
you changed my right now you're just
changing mine oh yo you
you were i thought it's just like look
at me look what i'm doing
yeah attention but then at the end of
the day it used to be just like that i'm
like man
why are you yeah you know but it's it's
there's just so much craziness in the
world
that's a good point you got to see some
some good my friend
donated 20 000 to like different
families on happy on he never like shows
it but i just feel like
a lot of he was getting a lot of flack
on like why he didn't speak up and stuff
like that he normally just like
donates and don't give and give and give
but then he felt like
i'm a document and show y'all what i do
he does this all the time he gave twenty
thousand dollars away
to different families wow which is where
like you don't have to don't happen
if you just do it just you know just you
know that happened a lot with recent
celebrities where
uh with all of these kind of like issues
with
i think it was black lives matter a lot
of people came out against beyonce
about not speaking up and stuff like
that and with politics like
people go after celebrities for not
saying that as if they owe
the public an explanation for what they
do behind them he was like bro this is
what i do i'm gonna show you instead of
saying something i'm gonna show you my
actions and this i'm helping families
yeah
just like it's again he didn't want to
do it because he's a private guy but the
fact that people was like
you know social media you said all the
time is not real he was like this is
what i'm doing in real life what are you
all doing with yourself yeah exactly
instead of typing you see what i'm
saying even then it's weird for him to
post i think what do you mean like who
gives a like if you're
moving like that you don't i don't think
i've ever posted that stuff i do yeah
not for christmas
or [ __ ] a lot of things i never post
either but i'm just saying people
i think that people like want to show
you like yo i'm a g like it's a lot of
genuine people in the world
but why do you feel you need to validate
it to like instagram but
to instagram well because i think that
the notion why would you give a flying
[ __ ] if someone's like oh he did donate
that money all right dude
cool man what i mean like another what
do you what are you saying
yeah well how he he was saying he moved
does a bunch of stuff like this help
people out
though i was like this is how i do it
yeah you know what i'm saying like
y'all don't think this is like who gives
a [ __ ] yeah
you know i don't know if you like if you
want to show it show it if you don't you
don't have to
that's how i feel i just think that
people like too many like everyone has
their own opinions and you're entitled
to that but the fact that
like you just can't judge someone off
like something like i don't want to say
anything but i'm doing stuff behind the
scenes i even be honest you don't have
to say anything
yeah exactly but if you want to document
it ain't nothing wrong with it yeah
but some people like the movement it's
like kevin hart was talking about it how
when the [ __ ] happened with nick cannon
they're like oh you're not gonna support
him not give it back he's like
you [ __ ] idiot he was at my house
yesterday thank you
how do you think he came but with the
moves he did who do you think made the
connections
who do you think called fox one but he's
with me right now
he's like he's like i don't have to post
all this [ __ ] yeah you don't know
but you see how he had to like like i
don't i wouldn't say cave to the
social media but you see how he had to
respond like bro kevin hart
yeah he always responds yeah he
entertains that yeah he always responds
even
the the the criticism again
what do you mean oh yeah where he had to
step down yeah before for an old
queen like that he already asked him
back
and he's like nah i'm good mm-hmm yeah
well look at his special he had his baby
uh in a little baby suit that said no
[ __ ] giving
for a special people gave him [ __ ]
people gave him [ __ ] he was like again
oh my god like i don't feel like
so you just have to address it but is it
is it everybody giving them [ __ ] or it's
just
it's just a small percentage yeah but
there's such a like
there's this clip that netflix posted
like i think it was uh
it was bill burr yeah on david spade's
new show
and fortunately femster was like um
you made a white woman mad at you
because of your snl monologue yeah but
he was like
he's like no they only interviewed the
ones that were mad he goes not everybody
was [ __ ] mad about it no the monster
is small it's such a small percentage of
people
so like is everybody upset about it no i
don't think it's
everybody it's just a [ __ ] small
percentage we just
and you don't want to answer give that
any energy yeah yeah you're answering to
a small percentage of people
you know what i mean for most people
when you post like yeah yeah it gives a
[ __ ]
yeah most of the time i scroll past the
[ __ ] i just think that like we
are as humans we are i want to say we
feel
positive positive things we're natural
it feels natural but something negative
you just like want to give that
attention because like it's unnatural
right everyone do you understand what
i'm saying
he literally doesn't have to answer
those [ __ ] but exactly he
doesn't have to be
because they don't change anything they
don't change anything he does no no
exactly all right did the grammys ask
him back they sure as [ __ ]
hell did yeah is he still kevin hart
yeah exactly just drop a new special on
netflix yeah
exactly so you're saying you're
basically saying you don't have to cater
people [ __ ] talking
i would never answer you too teflon
people's [ __ ] talking doesn't outweigh
someone's
talent of course you know what i mean if
the talent is there talent it's like the
same people get on like oh kevin's not
funny all right cool man
all right millions and millions of
people disagree thank you
and they're not giving comments correct
they're showing up the shows they're
building
shows yep they're buying these shows
that speaks louder than the [ __ ] talking
you don't have to entertain now if kevin
said something and then he wasn't
selling tickets he's not selling merch
or whatever then you you'd be
different okay then you got a problem
okay so you see you're basically saying
he has too much time addressing this i'm
saying don't cater to the minority okay
all right well yeah basically you came
in well that's what i guess celebrities
i just feel like you you get so much
heat because again
you want to be loved at the end of the
day you're a genuine guy you want to be
lucky
but i get what you're saying but listen
they want to address it like beyonce
she want to address she addressed it
like here money this is money that's
what i do
my friend this is what i do so kevin
hart this is what i do so it's just
i just think that people they can do
whatever they want yeah
they're still human also at the same
time not everyone's going to [ __ ]
like you
exactly but in that day they still human
which is which is [ __ ] fine
all right yeah you know if you're still
able to do what the [ __ ] you're able to
do yeah i don't think you know what have
you
liked would you say i don't think
anybody's universally like
that's horrible that'd be weird
what else you got jen oh this one is fun
so uh this woman her name is
maddie wright she's 22 years old and she
used to be a part of the
she was a charlton uh football player
over in the uk
and some photos of a porn star
named let's see her name was katie lulu
started surf surfacing on the internet
and people thought it was the soccer
player
and the soccer player uh eventually got
let go
of the team i'm not quite sure why but
what she ended up doing
this is the soccer player they confused
her with the porn star
and what ended up happening was because
she got so much
uh kind of like engagement on social
media because people thought she was the
porn actress
she started in only fans and is charging
24
pounds a month for content and now she's
killing it
what is your post stuff like this wait
did they let her go because people
thought she was a porn star i don't
know uh the way the article was titled
made it seem that way but when you read
it it seems like it might have been
something else she did
that might have been her skill set
question yeah if they mistake her for
a porn star right and she started only
fans
why would you pay for porn her only fans
where you can see
her they look just like her for free on
porn because she was a professional
soccer player
yeah she's still hot too yeah and she's
smoking
yeah okay there are some people also who
just kind of want to like support
certain people like oh you're like going
through hard times yeah and i don't want
to see her get
dp'd you know like i just want you maybe
in a felon you feel me i don't
i don't i don't see a cocky video of
this young girl
she wants to see her in her soccer
outfit
i'd rather pay for 24 how many powers
she got excuse me 148 000. oh so she
climbing okay she's climbing she's super
pretty can i see the porn store
just so yeah who's the partner yeah it's
like you said lululemon what's up
katie lulu i'm not familiar with the
tights
the workouts whatever you know katie
lulu is a porn star from the uk
all right oh [ __ ] oh go wait what are
those pictures right there
what pictures now right there on the
side you see what's going on no don't go
to those i can't go to those rooms stay
on the profile
do not hey that's also our porn stars
profile on twitter so
so they show stuff hopefully that's the
thing
chappelle hopefully dude that's the
point is that her right here i'll look
her up though
oh that's not her that's not her
instagram was for like a product was it
that one
i don't know what
what happened to twitter if you just
type i'm sure if you type in katie lulu
porno stuff but that's gonna show her
porn only i mean
we're just trying to see what she's
really gonna yeah the fans aren't gonna
see it yeah
all right here we go all right here we
go let's see if she looks like the girl
it's hard to tell from that angle no
they're all different girls
oh oh wait
okay all right they call her katie smith
katie smith that's her there jun
she does look like the other girl a
little bit they do look similar i do i
do
that's fair wow good for her
good for both of them i don't know right
oh she's got that belly button tattoo
like tyrix
that's the god smack yeah the guy's back
it's so funny she got live tattoo look
at the back tattoo
well good for her all right
congratulations man
all right hopefully those both of those
ladies are doing hopefully her only fans
blows up
she's super pretty yeah
chin has a virus now that's what he do
gotta clean up a little bit yeah that
makes sense yeah you're clearing your
browsing history
yeah you got this one burn oh do you see
this
now what happened let me see this is
dope so seattle was winning the game
right
yeah and all they had to do was take a
knee and they called in him to take a
knee
but he knew that his boy david moore a
receiver on the team if he caught one
more pass
he'd get a hundred thousand dollar bonus
so he audible the last play which is
super dangerous
just to throw him a shovel pass so he
got the bonus whoa
yeah the coach is pissed because he had
girls like what the [ __ ]
and then uh and then russell wilson told
him why he did it he started laughing
wait do we have the uh i don't think so
oh okay oh that's pretty pretty dope
he because he needed one more catch to
get his bonus he needed like
i think he had 59 catches if he got to
60. you hundred thousand dollars
damn his last play and they're like just
taking me he's like oh hell no
he got in his head he needs one more
catch and he knew that and audible that
line the coach was like what the [ __ ]
threw the ball out of them
and ran out of bounds that's so hard how
do you feel about them in the playoffs
i like they'll do what i like to see you
don't have a defense again my money is
on the saints
and we know why oh yeah okay right you
got a big bet on you got a big bed seven
pairs of shoes
seven pairs so i can't wait no he's got
to get you seven pairs right yeah yeah
he'll get me one you guys yeah but you
already lost one bit
to him correct yeah he lost two
weeks into him the football no no no we
bet
fully we bet the football which is
monday no house day oh yeah
yeah no no i didn't bet you i bet you oh
yeah i meant justin yeah
got it is that it want some more good
we're good yeah all right that's it kids
uh san marcos texas only seats that are
left are those big tables but i think
they're gonna break them up their tables
are like eight and ten which is
ridiculous
january 29th through the 30th san marcos
texas
uh come get some texas t5k.com for
tickets hey let's eat good in texas
you want to eat because i mean let's
let's texas just got it let's die
but texas let's go off i'm in man taxes
come get it thick boy gear thickboy.com
just uh restocked all the [ __ ] there the
specialized collab drops this month as
well
dickboy.com t5k.com for tickets in san
marcos texas get em we out